[Music]
on this Monday night powered down
construction stops on an electric
vehicle battery plant in Ontario why the
federal government is being blamed there
are 2500 jobs at stake
the battle against a ballooning Alberta
Wildfire the exhausted evacuees we don't
know when we get to go home the
obstacles for firefighters and what's
expected to keep fueling the flames
prices trending upwards how Canada's
real estate market is heating up
the national
good evening and thanks for joining us
one of the world's biggest automakers
says it has stopped construction of a
multi-billion dollar electric vehicle
battery plant in Ontario Dutch company
stalantis claims the government has not
delivered on what was agreed to last
year when it signed a deal with the
federal and Ontario governments since
then Volkswagen was given 13 billion
dollars in subsidies to build a battery
plant in Canada and it seems now there
is a battle over subsidies underway
turia Israeli has our top story tonight
an electric vehicle battery plant could
be dead before it's even built one of
the world's biggest automakers has shut
down Construction in Windsor Ontario
saying the government did not live up to
its end of the bargain but refusing to
explain how it really worries me you
know we we need the federal government
to step up dutch-based stalantis and
South Korean battery maker LG unveiled
their plans for a 5 billion dollar
facility last year with a billion
dollars coming in the form of government
subsidies it'll deliver for our economy
and it'll deliver for the environment at
the time the stalantis project was
billed as the largest Automotive
investment in Canadian history that was
before the Volkswagen deal
prime minister Justin Trudeau an Ontario
Premier Doug Ford announced 13 billion
dollars in public money for the German
company to build an EV battery plant in
Saint Thomas Ontario less than a month
later stalantis threatened to scrap its
project and the 2500 jobs that come with
it the opposition accuses the Liberals
of bungling negotiations the prime
minister is up puffing and puffing last
week now we find six days later that
construction in the five billion dollar
facility has halted because of his
incompetence the Liberals are trying to
compete with massive government spending
in the U.S on Green Technology as part
of the inflation reduction Act
but Deputy Prime Minister Christia
Freeland says resources are not infinite
we are counting on Ontario to do its
fair share and we're counting on
stellantis to be reasonable automotive
industry experts believe stalantis may
be posturing to get the feds to match
the massive subsidies given to
Volkswagen well it's not the first time
stalantis has done something like that
negotiations with stellantis are ongoing
but if the automaker decides to pull out
it could complicate Canada's plans to
become a major EV player Donna teria
Israel and Ottawa thanks now to the
growing wildfires threatening
communities across parts of western
Canada tonight dozens are burning out of
control this dramatic footage is a
massive fire just five kilometers from
the town of Fox Creek in Northern
Alberta firefighters are working around
the clock to try to stop it from
reaching homes in that Community there
are evacuation orders in place for
communities in BC Alberta Saskatchewan
and the Northwest Territories emergency
crews are battling dozens of fires many
of them still out of control in BC
Alberta and Saskatchewan and the high
temperatures and smoke have prompted
Environment Canada to issue heat alerts
and special air quality statements
stretching from the West Coast all the
way to Ontario Global's Marnie blunt is
in Fox Creek Alberta tonight Marnie
Donna the race to fight the Flames here
in Fox Creek has taken on a new level of
urgency with the Wildfire now growing to
more than 33 000 hectares in size a
giant sitting on the community's
doorstep
a battle against the Blaze from the sky
and on the ground
this video not shot by global news shows
how aggressive the fire fight is in the
thick of it just west of Fox Creek
Alberta Alberta Wildfire Crews working
around the clock to save the town with
intense heat and Flames now facing Crews
about five kilometers Northeast of the
community heavy smoke is also
restricting where air Crews can fly
tensions running high with tender dry
conditions unseasonably warm
temperatures and the winds Now set to
shift we have been told that tonight
tomorrow the winds are going to shift so
if that happens then things might not be
so favorable for our community
Fox Creek employees who stayed behind to
staff the Emergency Operations Center
may also be forced to leave on a
moment's notice over 1800 residents
forced to flee many staying in hotels in
the nearby community of White Court
coming to the evacuees center each day
to find support and community a lot of
the families are exhausted also very
concerned still we have been providing
mental health supports our family
support workers have been available the
mayor says for many the initial Panic is
starting to fade and evacuees are now
growing weary I've seen so many
different emotions but now I'm starting
to see things change people are really
tired we're on day nine we don't know
when we get to go home so definitely
things are back to that real emotional
roller coaster where where you're on a
real low right now on Monday Wildfire
crews in the air we're working to drop a
flame retardant around the community
while Crews on the ground were working
with bulldozers trying to build a guard
wall around the town hoping to keep the
Flames at Bay with many uncertain of
what the next few days will bring Donna
uncertainty Marnie blunt in Fox Creek
Alberta thanks
it's been a dry spring and now
temperatures have soared in the Wildfire
Zone Global News meteorologist TIffany
Lee Zay is in Calgary Tiffany what's the
forecast and what kind of wildfire
season is this shaping up to be Donna we
had a ridge of high pressure build
itself back over parts of western Canada
and that allowed for a heat dome which
is a high pressure system that has hot
air trapped within it that allowed for a
heat Dome to park itself over western
Canada and that is what Alberta and BC
have been dealing with there is still a
special weather statement that blankets
a large part of BC as well as heat
warnings in parts of BC Northern Alberta
as temperatures are 15 to 25 degrees
above seasonal for this time of year and
this heat isn't going anywhere
throughout this week or even the weekend
the heat Dome is going to sit over
western Canada throughout this week when
we finally start to see that breakdown
is when we get past May long weekend and
once we get into the middle of the work
week next week then some cooler air will
start to take over if we're looking even
farther ahead as we finish off Spring
and get into summer we have the El Nino
slowly starting to build and because
it's building slowly we are expecting
these hotter than seasonal temperatures
to continue so this is a look at the
temperature anomaly for May so you can
see how hot it's been and will continue
to be now once we get into June you're
seeing a lot of those shades of yellow
and orange that's showing you where
temperatures will be above seasonal that
Trend extends into July and even in two
parts of August when we're talking
moisture May has been incredibly dry for
both BC and Alberta as we look towards
June it does look like we should have a
little more moisture which should help
that Wildfire situation but come July
some of those drier conditions are
expected to return so we'll be watching
that Wildfire situation very closely
over the next few months Donna all right
Global News meteorologist TIffany Lee
Zay thanks
prime minister Justin Trudeau was in
Edmond today getting a briefing from the
Canadian Armed Forces Personnel helping
fight the fires about 300 soldiers are
being deployed providing firefighting
support and airlift resources the prime
minister is now on his way to his first
official visit to South Korea before
attending the G7 Summit in Japan
Canadians in four Federal ridings will
be voting for new members of parliament
next month there are by-elections in two
Manitoba writings one in rural Ontario
and another in Downtown Montreal the
outcomes won't upset the balance of
power in Parliament but there are some
interesting races our chief political
correspondent David Aiken breaks down
what to watch David thanks Donna let's
start on the Prairies let's go to
Winnipeg and then Southern Manitoba this
is the riding of Portage lisgar and in
2021 this writing was won by the
conservative Candace Bergen but look who
finished second The People's Party of
Canada got more than 20 percent of the
vote nearly ten thousand people this was
the best result for a PPC candidate
anywhere in the country except in the
riding of Bose in Quebec where the PPC
leader Maxine Bernier was running and
would finish second well guess what
Bernier is running here in this
by-election that's right Bernie will run
in Portage lisgar on June 19th and
you'll remember back in 21 in 2021 the
PPC really found its energy by
harnessing the anger around vaccine
mandates and public health guidelines
and so does that anger still exist in
our politics we're going to find out in
this particular by-election there's
another seat open in Manitoba and it is
in Winnipeg it's the writing right here
of Winnipeg South Center and in 2021 Jim
Carr won that writing Jim passed away in
December but picking up his torch his
son Ben has won the liberal nomination
it's a pretty safe liberal seat a guy
named Lloyd axworth he got his start
here a long time ago now let's move to
another safe liberal region this is the
island of Montreal there's all the red
seats from 2021 with some BQ seats here
and right here a very safe seat Mark
garneau the former astronaut has retired
liberals looking for someone to succeed
him in that riding and finally we go to
a conservative safe seat right here in
the heartland of Southwestern Ontario
between kitchen and Waterloo in London
the seat is called Oxford Dave McKenzie
won this seven times in a row for the
conservatives and Mackenzie wanted to
pass the seed on to his daughter but his
daughter failed to win the nomination
lost it to an inside uh Circle person
from Pierre pauliev's team and that
really upset Dave McKenzie so much so
McKenzie's voting for the liberal in
this by-election Donna all right David
Akin and Ottawa thank you the Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski made his
fourth surprise visit to a Western
European nation in three days he went to
the UK today to meet the British prime
minister zielinski is making these
personal visits to shore up support for
his country in its battle against Russia
and as Redmond Shannon reports he's also
pushing again for NATO countries to
supply fighter jets
the final stop on Vladimir zielinski's
tour of Europe's big four economic
powers
after a weekend in Rome Berlin and Paris
it was the warm embrace of Checkers on
Monday the country residents of British
prime minister Rishi sunak Winston
Churchill made many of his famous
speeches in World War II from this run
the complex three-day Security operation
for face time with these European
leaders has paid off for zelenski the UK
joined France and Germany's weekend
pledges by promising hundreds of air
defense missiles and armed drones just
days after it donated long-range cruise
missiles we're a temple from all our
hearts from ukrainians all the equipment
will be used in Ukraine's anticipated
spring counter-offensive but in reality
trips like these for zelenski are about
securing the next donations and top of
his list are F-16 fighter jets today we
spoke about the Jets and I see that in
the closest time you will hear some I
think very important decisions neither
the UK nor Canada own f-16s but the U.S
Poland and others do zelenski wants a
coalition of countries to help Ukraine
with the complex training and
infrastructure that the planes would
need
French president Emmanuel macron says he
is on board a spokesperson for Canada's
Minister for National Defense Anita
Anand told Global News only that she
remains in close contact with Ukrainian
officials about their most pressing
security needs no country has yet gone
really serious with looking into how and
when such delivery would be possible so
the timeline is is open but it will be
months at the earliest before any f-16s
are patrolling Ukrainian Skies an
acknowledgment from zelenski that even
if the upcoming counter-offensive is a
success it is unlikely to end the 4.
Redmond Shannon double news London
an election in Thailand could end almost
a decade of military-backed rule in that
country
[Applause]
152 of 500 seats the party leader says
they've agreed to an alliance with five
other parties creating a 309 seat
Coalition that doesn't guarantee they'll
form government though an unelected
military-appointed 250 member Senate can
also join in on the vote to appoint the
Prime Minister and it's expected to vote
against the move forward party
there is more evidence tonight the
benefits of hormone replacement therapy
outweigh the risks for many women with
symptoms of menopause new Canadian
research suggests it should be offered
to more women in their 40s and 50s the
paper published in the Canadian Medical
Association Journal shows hormone
replacement therapy can treat
debilitating symptoms such as hot
flashes disrupted sleep and mood
disturbances some doctors have been
hesitant to prescribe it since a flawed
study in the 1990s linked hormone
replacement therapy with higher risks of
breast cancer and stroke experts now say
those risks were overstated and were
mostly associated with women 60 and
older
the weather is warming up and so is the
housing market coming up how much the
average Canadian home is now going for
Canada's housing market is showing some
signs of recovery home sales jumped by
double digits last month the latest
report from the Canadian Real Estate
Association shows just over 44 000 homes
were sold in April and 11.3 percent
increase from March the average home
price in April was seven hundred and
sixteen thousand dollars that is down
3.9 percent year over year but it's up
more than one hundred thousand dollars
from January of this year the uptick
follows a pause on interest rate hikes
by the Bank of Canada
Vice media has filed for bankruptcy
protection as it struggles with a
changing landscape for digital media the
company behind the online content
Outlets Vice and motherboard says it's
agreed to sell its assets to a
Consortium of lenders in exchange for
about 225 million U.S in credit the sale
is expected to complete in the next two
to three months until then content will
still be produced and the company will
continue to pay employees last month a
restructuring plan saw the cancellation
of its Flagship program Vice news
tonight and dozens of layoffs
people and processing ahead the new
strains on America's immigration system
[Music]
in the U.S officials say there's been a
dramatic decline in migrants trying to
cross the southern border tens of
thousands of people had rushed to enter
the country before the expiration of
title 42 a strict pandemic policy that
denied people the right to seek Asylum
but allowed them to keep trying now they
can face expedited removal and
potentially face criminal charges if
they attempt to enter the U.S again
Jackson prosco reports
these are desperate times that the U.S
Mexico border where thousands of
migrants now face a difficult choice
they can attempt to cross illegally and
risk being banned from the U.S or they
can apply for an appointment to try and
claim Asylum
we don't know what happens if you cross
illegally says this Venezuelan migrant
who was hopeful he would have his Asylum
appeal granted the new rules came into
effect Friday after a pandemic era
prohibition on Asylum Seekers known as
title 42 expired now you have to have
either have applied for and received a
denial of protection in one of the
transit countries that you came through
or you have to have an appointment so
far it seems to have worked the United
States border patrol has seen an
approximately 50 percent drop in the
number of people encountered at our
Southern border
that hasn't eased the strain from tens
of thousands of migrants who rushed to
the U.S before the rules changed near
the border processing centers are
overcrowded while many migrants were
bussed to cities far away where shelters
are overwhelmed many of these migrants
have been dumped in our neighborhoods
without a plan in place to Monitor and
house them long term the U.S says that
under the new policy several thousand
migrants have since been returned to
Mexico there's still no long-term plan
for reforming the U.S immigration system
I think this is not a Democratic or
republican problem it's an American
problem and things should have been done
a long time ago without a fix the Border
remains a Beacon of Hope for people from
around the world
desperate for a better life willing to
risk it all
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
dreams dashed next the continuation of
Canada's Stanley Cup drought
[Music]
well it's hard to find a bright side
today if you were hoping for a Canadian
team to make it to the Stanley Cup
finals the elimination of the Edmonton
Oilers and the Toronto Maple Leafs over
the weekend means it's now been 30 years
without a cup Tonight Eric Sorensen
takes a shot at why our teams can't
quite make it
you could feel it coming and the crowd
went quiet and soon the last Canadian
team standing was down and out it's like
an annual Rite of Spring disappointment
in Canadian NHL cities Connor McDavid a
man of few words at the best of times
we're all just the opportunity last year
certainly yeah you said it and every
year imagining what might have been
there's moments we want to have back and
and we're going to have to learn from to
use this as the growth opportunity that
it presents but it seems we're always
learning not winning really unfortunate
like
futility
annually
no Canadian team has won the Stanley Cup
since Montreal's win in 1993. before
that it was Edmonton in 1990 a year
earlier Calgary's only cup Toronto has
the longest drought in NHL history and
of course Vancouver Winnipeg and Ottawa
have never won so in the last 30 years
zero Stanley Cups for Canadian cities
and just to compare in the previous 50
years Canadian teams won 35 Stanley Cups
and now for Canadian fans it feels like
we're on the outside looking in there
are many factors so many more American
teams in the NHL nowadays warm weather
and low taxes in some U.S markets but in
the salary cap era there's little
Financial excuse for not winning at
least once in a while it's got to really
come down to the quality of management
that that's that's really the bottom
line I think
the Toronto Maple Leafs are almost the
definition of Stanley Cup failure
haven't been even to the finals in 56
years well on a day like today it's
really tough to to feel or sense any
sort of progress but I do feel we've
made progress as a group and one reason
not to panic the biggest American Star
says he wants to stay and win in Toronto
I think I've uh you know reciprocated
that before how much I enjoy playing
here and what it means to me remember
every Stanley Cup winner relies heavily
on Canadian talent there are five
manitobans alone on the Vegas golden
knights who are still alive but that is
cold comfort for millions of Canadians
who are tired of being shut out in the
Stanley Cup Playoffs every year Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is Bark Lake near the township of
Madawaska Valley Ontario we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]